the tails series has been one of the
most iconic jrpgs that has stuck to its
roots heavily
throughout the years evolving in fun
i'll be at small steps that hasn't
changed the formula much
but tales of a rise feels like the
biggest step into the next generation so
far
while still making any tails fan feel
right at home we will be reviewing the
full game when it arrives so be sure to
subscribe to be notified when the full
review drops
our preview of tales of arise drops us
in the very beginning of the game
starting us off with a masked slave
named iron mask simply living day by day
with his identity and his past
completely forgotten
but after a run-in with a girl on the
run named xion they both join a
resistance group to fight against the
running oppression
and both begin to unravel bits of their
past the kicker is that shion is unable
to be touched with anyone who does
getting a healthy dose of lightning
don't touch me
it's not your fault kid while iron mask
has the unusual ability of being unable
to feel any pain
this sets off an interesting
relationship between the two
protagonists as he is the only person
who is able to touch cheon
and her mental barrier of never being
able to be touched is broken for the
first time
the tales series has always been about
the relationships between party members
and that feels stronger than ever here
even with the short preview that we had
one of the new ways tales of arise has
evolved is in its iconic character
building skits
in previous games it's always been the
same talking heads approach
while tales of arise takes on a motion
comic book angle and is a refreshing
change while sticking to the tales
pattern
as the story is told through beautiful
anime cutscenes in-game cutscenes
motion comics and the standard text
boxes its mix of mediums hits just right
another thing noticeable right off the
bat is a presentation
while the standard anime style look is
there it's matured both metaphorically
and
literally the voice work and dialogue
while hitting some normal anime tropes
feels a little bit more realistic and
believable compared to previous titles
and the semi-washed out environments and
the more adult looking characters
brings a very welcome new palette change
traversing the world can be engaging as
well with a system of limited cp
or cure points which are tied to healing
support abilities
and taking down blocked terrain in the
world this creates a system where you
simply can't spam healing as a primary
way to refill cure points is by resting
at an inn or at a campground
thinking critically about when and where
to use your precious resource points as
you're playing brings an interesting
layer to the simple dungeon aspect
and gives it more of a feeling of being
a dungeon run rather than simply walking
around and fighting baddies
although this could be a system that can
be seen as an annoyance to some players
oh and as a first in the tail series you
can jump while exploring and access new
areas
nothing mind-boggling but as a longtime
tails fan this is definitely a welcome
new addition
combat is back in its frenetic and
conventional tales formula with
combos arts apple gels and all you'll be
hitting standard attacks with the goal
of breaking the enemy's guard and
continuing your combo
including launching them to get some
extra aerial hits in
defensive abilities such as blocking
dodge rolls and perfect dodge
rolls into counter attacks are all
present as well boost attacks fill in a
gauge over time that can be used to call
in allies at key moments to cover gaps
in combos
or assist attacks while you heal up and
each character has unique abilities that
only they can perform such as special hp
sacrificing powerful attacks that iron
mask can do
and a special bomb attack that xion can
snipe to do more damage
this being a chapter 1 preview build we
obviously couldn't see the whole extent
of the combat system
but the little taste that we had got us
itching for more and is a promising
appetizer for the rest of the game
as a person who holds tales of zinfonia
vesperia and axelia very dearly
bandai namco's tales of her rise seems
like a return to form
and a refreshing evolution since its
consistent format set back in 1995.
it's set to release on ps4 and 5 xbox
one series x and s
and pc on september 10th now we've got
some extra unedited gameplay for you to
watch
for everything else gaming keep it here
on gamespot
[Music]
this could be useful
here let me help
[Music]
you're finished i'll try harder
[Music]
that's what i like to hear
[Music]
[Music]
i hate camping out
hurry up and go to sleep i can think for
myself you know
yeah but the last thing i need is you
dragging me down because you're too
tired
i'll keep that in mind
all done come and eat
[Music]
well off we go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's this thing
that's one enormous stray i don't think
we can take it right now
[Music]
i thought him like this should be easy
[Music]
i'll take you all off
try harder
[Music]
let's keep our eyes on the prize
[Music]
[Music]
it's over
[Music]
these little ones are hard to work on
let's talk them apart
let's keep our eyes on the prize
[Music]
that's an unusual bird it's an owl
they're often used as a symbol to
represent ancient dana